[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 23 juin près de
500 élèves et 12 communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont retrouvés à l'occasion
d'une journée olympique au golf national
découverte sportive rencontre avec des
athlètes de haut niveau ou encore
démonstrations et performance
nous reviendrons sur cette journée
olympique à houilles les pompiers sont
intervenus près de 150 fois après de
violents orages qui ont provoqué des
inondations dans la commune au total ces
300 foyers qui sont coupés d'électricité
la protection civile et la croix rouge
ont été mobilisés
enfin focus sur l'entrepreneuriat
étudiant nous irons rencontrer une
vingtaine d'étudiants de l'école et
c'est au pari vélizy et notre invité à
ce sujet patrick jean pierre professeur
au sein du pépite peps le pôle
entrepreneuriat et innovation de paris
saclay est aussi un point sur le nouveau
centre de vaccination de vélizy
[Musique]
comme je vous le disais en titre près de
500 élèves des douze communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont retrouvés à l'occasion
d'une journée olympique au golf national
ce mercredi 23 juin
l'occasion de faire des découvertes
sportives ou encore de rencontrer les
athlètes de haut niveau
le reportage de grégory kahn allait y
séjourner
parce qu'on ne garde pas d'activité par
le sport qu'on n'a pas testé
on a fait dieu de tir au pistolet et on
a fait de la course
ça fait du bien au corps ici c'est
amusant si tous les dlc la génération
2024 ces jeunes vont vivre dans trois
ans les jeux olympiques en france et
pour faire monter l'engouement saint
quentin en yvelines a convié cinq cents
élèves de 18 collèges de l'agglomération
au golf national ce mercredi 23 juin une
trentaine d'ateliers au programme pour
découvrir les disciplines olympiques et
paralympiques
c'est une manière très importante de
permettre aux enfants de s'accaparer les
jeux olympiques et les valeurs de
l'olympisme qui sont très très
importante des valeurs du sport mais les
valeurs de l'olympisme tout
particulièrement si j'ai quatre les bras
pratiquement toute la place cette
journée était aussi l'occasion pour ces
jeunes de faire la connaissance de
sportifs de haut niveau parmi les
athlètes présents l'ancien handballeur
olivier girault capitaine de l'équipe de
france championne du monde en 2001 et
médaillé d'or aux jo de pékin en 2008
moi petit c'est comme ça aussi que j'ai
évolué j'aurais voulu que des champions
qu'on réussit qui ont réussi reviennent
transmettent c'est un plaisir de
devenir transmettent et il ya plein de
gamins plein d'éducateurs plane
bénévoles voilà tout l'écosystème du
sport ai réunis c'est une super
initiative donc obligatoire d'être
présent à la mi journée les jeunes ont
pu assister à des démonstrations du
tumbling avec la présence d'axel duriez
du club des clayes-sous-bois double
champion du monde des 13 14 ans bmx flat
football freestyle ou encore breakdance
la discipline sera olympique en 2024
c'est important de la faire connaître
d'ici là pour carlotta dudek
à 19 ans elle rêve de participer aux jo
de paris ça permet un petit peu d'avoir
un premier contact avec nous et du coup
nous ensuite on va pouvoir échanger avec
leurs deux noms rigolos rapport à mes
mouvements
donc nous c'est tout ce qu'on aime
pouvoir leur montrer leur apprendre et
et à y avoir leurs manuels et tout leur
intérêt et un belge
saint quentin en yvelines accueillera
cinq épreuves des jo en 2024 au golf et
vélodrome nationale et sur la colline
d'elancourt rendez vous donné dès
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
journée olympique direction où il ya
présence ou les pompiers sont intervenus
plus de 150 fois ce mardi 2 22 juin
suite aux inondations qui ont démarré
tôt dans la matinée dès 9h30 la
protection civile et la croix rouge ont
été mobilisés à la demande de la région
valérie pécresse s'est également rendu
sur place
reportage d'astrid bergère et bérangère
bourgoin la ville de houilles a été
violemment touchés par les orages mardi
22 juin dès 9h30 la commune a été inondé
les commerces et habitations ont été
impactés on essaie de voir en fait soit
puisque même ça commence à monter sur le
salon donc ça on va y aller chez des
amis ou sur la famille ou sinon
c'est ça c'est compliqué justement on va
voir comment ça va se faire avec la
protection civile et on va s'organiser
avec comme ça une trentaine d'habitants
a été mis au sec et hébergés au total
ces 300 foyers qui sont coupés
d'électricité
donc aujourd'hui on a quasiment tous les
quartiers de la ville qui ont été
touchés donc on a plusieurs centaines de
personnes et plusieurs dizaines de votre
domicile qui ont été touchés on a
énormément de commerces du centre-ville
qui ont été impactés on a plusieurs
commerces qu'on 55 cm d'eau là dans la
différentes parties de la ville donc là
ça a été assez massif
la présidente du conseil régional est
candidate à sa réélection valérie
pécresse s'est rendue sur place hier en
fin d'après midi les bénévoles de la
protection civile sont mobilisés à la
demande de la région pour venir en aide
notamment aux habitants
nous avons aussi un autre partenariat
avec la croix rouge qui est en train de
monter un gymnase d'hébergement
d'urgence à la demande du maire et nous
allons faire venir des food truck pour
pouvoir servir des repas d'urgence et
l'adaptation de la ville au dérèglement
climatique
c'est une compétence aujourd'hui qui est
une compétence de l'état
et moi je pense qu'elle devrait
décentralisée à la région aucun blessé
n'est à déplorer le maire va également
demander de faire reconnaître cet
épisode orageux en état de catastrophe
naturelle
la député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines à marie le bec a elle aussi
fait la demande que la commune de où ils
soient reconnues en état de catastrophe
naturelle tout comme celle de carrières
sur seine
[Musique]
nous ouvrons entre thématique du jour ce
sont peut-être des futurs entrepreneurs
une vingtaine d'étudiants de l'école et
c'est au pari vélizy ont présenté leur
projet dans le cadre d'un forum
industriel
cet établissement spécialisé dans la
formation d'ingénieur à mise à l'honneur
des élèves en accueillant des
représentants d'entreprises ou des
institutionnels les détails dans ce
reportage de nicolas landry et choristes
et mme chagnon un magic cube un bras
robotique ou encore une ferme verticale
quelques exemples parmi les 11 projets
industriels présentés par les étudiants
de l'école d'ingénieurs aisé au pari
vélizy c'est le cas de près si la bnsa
dit étudiante en quatrième année en
ingénierie d'affaires elle a développé
avec ses camarades un projet autour de
la rénovation énergie
tic notre projet a été de réaliser une
action de performance énergétique sont
l'ensemble de notre campus afin du coup
d'améliorer ses performances
premièrement il a été déjà important de
réaliser une audi du bâtiment par
exemple pourquoi pas installer de
nouvelles fenêtres qui s'adapterait du
coup à l'éblouissement du soleil ou des
radiateurs thermiques qui sont composés
de microprocesseurs qui chauffera la
salle grâce à ses microprocesseurs
voilà plein d'action futuriste autre
projet avec cet outil programmé pour
distribuer les médicaments à leur donner
le pilier est connecté à une application
donc sur cette application on va entrer
le nom des médicaments donc là on nous
avons deux noms de médicaments rentrée
une fois connecté on a juste besoin de
se connecter au bluetooth
une fois connecté on peut faire
directement envoyées et les médicaments
seront sortis alors souhaité le campus
et 0 paris iv l'isie a été créé en 2018
ces 230 élèves cette année répartis dans
quatre options le big data la
cybersécurité l'ingénierie et
l'intelligence artificielle 96 % des
étudiants connaissent une insertion
professionnelle à la sortie de l'école
objectif former de futurs ingénieurs et
même parfois de futurs entrepreneurs
avec un accompagnement spécifique
très concrètement alors fait une
présentation de comment déjà on pilote
la création d'une entreprise ou d'une
structure de l'idée première jusqu'à
l'étude de la viabilité et cetera de
l'entreprise dont qu'ils ont une
personne référente sur le campus ici qui
peut les accompagner sur les différentes
étapes du projet et peut-être qu'un
futur entrepreneur se trouve parmi ces
onze projets présentés lors du premier
forum industriel de l'école et 0 paris
vélizy et demain jeudi 24 juin ce qui
cube lu vs cul et l'estaca organise une
journée dédiée à l'entrepreneuriat
étudiant pour parler de cette journée
mais aussi de cette thématique de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant et de ses
modalités
nous accueillons patrick jeantet re
bonsoir alors vous êtes professeur en
entrepreneuriat si on peut dire ça au
sein d'une paix du pépite peps le pôle
entrepreneuriat et innovation
paris-saclay associé à l'unive
cité versailles-saint-quentin lu vs qu
d'abord patrick d'inter qu'est ce que
c'est que l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
alors c'est tout une démarche à la fois
de cours d'ateliers de tutorat qui
permet d'emmener un étudiant depuis sont
des justes la création d'entreprise et
donc lui permettent de venir ce marché
présenter son nouveau produit son
nouveau service donner corps et vie à
son idée de a à z
quel est le profil de ces étudiants
entrepreneurs que vous accueillez vous
mais en général
alors ça va aujourd'hui de la licence
jusqu'au master 2 même jusqu'au doctorat
n'accompagnons des projets extrêmement
il est revenu il anime ça peut aller de
projets sur la robotique le big data à
des projets supplément effectifs voire
même à la production artistique on a
vraiment des problèmes les compétences
variées ce qu'il dit c'est ce qui en a
justement a parfois des projets la
démarche et quelles sont les modalités
de ce statut d'étudiant entrepreneurs
après il s'agit du statut national
d'étudiants l'entrepreneur qu'on peut
soit obtenir pendant ses études il y a
aujourd'hui une vingtaine de projets qui
sont suivis à l'université versailles
saint quentin taux long de leur cursus
normal des plots mme avec lorsque c'est
possible évidemment des aménagements sur
les courts sur les stages pour ceux qui
sont en formation initiale puisque moi
j'ai eu déjà des étudiants qui ont fait
leurs sacs sur leur propre entreprise en
fait qu'ils avaient créées donc ça c'est
pendant que vous faites de votre
formation jusqu'au diplôme et après le
diplôme vous pouvez aussi bénéficier de
ce fait une nationale des étudiants
entrepreneurs au travers du diplôme
étudiants entrepreneurs de paris saclay
qui vous conduit pendant un an
éventuellement deux ans en poste diplôme
sur la maturation de votre idée et après
ce sont d'autres partenaires qu'ils
prennent le relais puisque nous
travaillons avec les incubateurs du
territoire que ce soit ce qui cube
effectivement sur le territoire saint
quentin en yvelines où incuballiance ou
même notre partenaire matrix et d'autres
sur paris ou sur saclay voilà
chacun joue son rôle pour accompagner
pour permettre le financement de ces
projets et pour les amener en viabilité
sur le marché y at il des craintes quand
on se lance en tant qu'étudiant en tant
que jeune du coup dans l'entrepreneuriat
alors oui évidemment il ya beaucoup
d'opportunités il ya aussi des risques à
la clé qui est entrepreneur c'est aussi
gérer son risque évidemment le premier
c'est le temps il faut pouvoir dédier du
temps il faut pouvoir dédier de
l'énergie c'est pour ça que lors de nos
comités d'engagement tout ça soit en
juillet ou en janvier de chaque année
nous regardons étroitement et de très
près la motivation des étudiants qui
viennent soit seul soit environ entre
innove pour être sûr qu'ils iront
jusqu'au bout de leur idée donc le temps
la motivation c'est quelque chose de
primordial
après on les accompagne tout au long du
cheminement donc leur cour je dirais à
l'étude de marché dans au lard apprend à
faire le recours au financement il
rentre dans un réseau de relations qui
leur parlait d'aller chercher des prêts
d'honneur des contacts avec la bpi la
banque etc et qui permet effectivement
d' aller étape par étape au contact du
client contacte des fournisseurs en
contact des partenaires voilà et c'est
ça que nous au sein du réseau dépit de
peps de tous les campus accompagnent
nous pouvons leur facilité tout au long
de l'année
alors on en parlait tout à l'heure
demain jeudi 24 juin une journée dédiée
du coup est organisée à
l'entrepreneuriat à saint quentin en
yvelines sur l'entrepreneuriat utilisant
pardonnez moi quel va être son programme
et quel est son but et c'est de cette
journée alors nous avons effectivement a
souhaité organiser cette journée
complète avec notre partenaire ce qui
cube avec est chouette remercier jean
luc berho valérie carew qui sont nos
contacts privilégiés ainsi que
évidemment tous les services de saint
quentin qui nous ont accompagnés nous
avons monté ce programme au sein de
versailles saint quentin avec une
collègue virginie à branco et notre vice
président philippe cocu et l'estaca avec
mon collègue stéphane minson voilà c'est
un programme qui s'est monté depuis
plusieurs mois
nous souhaitons organiser le matin un
star game avec notre partenaire matrix
qui va leur permettre d'expérimenter des
méthodes comme le design thinking pour
réfléchir à l'aménagement et
l'accessibilité ville en prévision des
jeux paralympiques de 2024 donc c'est un
sujet à la fois riche d'innovation de
créativité mais on va les accompagner
sur deux heures en équipe pour essayer
de donner vie à ce projet de le
prototype et et de le pitch est comme
s'il était effectivement en situation
devant des investisseurs et l'après midi
avec le design spot de paris saclay avec
vincent créances et son équipe nous
allons leur permet de participer à un
atelier sur ce côté que le design ce que
ça apporte une entreprise de s'asseoir
un produit innovant sur un site web sur
la manière d'appréhender le véritable
besoin du client de se mettre dans les
chaussures du client et l'utilisateur
est d'être capable d'innover pas
seulement technologiquement mais aussi
en termes d'ergonomie en serre en terme
de beauté l'idée produire si tout
simplement de prise en main et de bien
comprendre l'aspect complet systémique
que peut avoir un nouveau produit
lorsqu'ils arrivent sur le marché
une journée donc riche en enseignements
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on souhaite
merci patrick inter d'avoir été avec
nous pour cette édition dans le reste de
l'actualité depuis le 15 juin le centre
commercial westfield des visites deux
âmes ouvert un centre de vaccination
2000 m² 30 agents administratifs et
médicaux
le centre et sans rendez-vous et gratuit
est accessible jusqu'au 28 août
reportage d'astrid bergère nouveaux
centres de vaccination dans les yvelines
il est ouvert depuis le 15 juin au
centre commercial westfield vélizy 2 un
espace de 2000 m² mise à disposition par
le centre en collaboration avec les
autorités afin de favoriser
l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
je crois que le le souhait de la
préfecture de la rs et du département
c'était véritablement d'aller à la
rencontre des gens ils les centres de
vaccination sur rendez vous c'est je
fais une démarche proactive ici c'est
encore plus dynamique
le centre se déplacer vient à la
rencontre de nos clients ils sont
nombreux et ont peu profité d'une séance
shopping de courses alimentaires pour
faire en 20 minutes une vaccination
libre gratuite et sans rendez vous c'est
le point le plus important c'est les
vaccins de pfizer qui administre et dans
ce centre sans rendez-vous il attire les
volontaires je pensais que c'était
important de se faire vacciner donc
étant donné qu on nous mettait la
vaccination sans rendez vous je trouvais
que c'était plutôt pratique donc je suis
venu pour moi c'était c'était vraiment
enfin ça rend la chose vraiment beaucoup
plus facile
c'est simple parce que ces procès sans
rendez-vous les 12 17 ans peuvent se
faire vacciner depuis le 15 juin mais
dans ces centres ils sont assez peu
nombreux ces derniers jours on a
constaté qu'à peu près 10% des gens que
nous accueillons et elle est mineure de
12 à 18 ans donc c'est plutôt un bon
démarrage vraiment ici on lance un appel
à tout tous ces jeunes qui vont partir
en vacances qui vont sortir à peu faire
la fête pour se protéger protéger leurs
proches en venant rapidement sans
rendez-vous gratuitement sur l'acné avec
l'autorisation de leurs deux parents
bien évidemment le centre de vaccination
de westfield vélizy 2 est ouvert du
mardi au samedi de 10 heures à 18 heures
et ce jusqu'au 28 août
pour refermer cette édition la mairie
d'andrésy vient de procéder à l'anru
charge de son tout nouveau ruchers
municipale sise essaim d'abeilles noires
sont donc les nouveaux voisins de la
maison du moussel et de l'hôtel de ville
regardez 12000 habitants est désormais
six ruches la municipalité d'andrésy
vient d'installer des essaims d'abeilles
noires à proximité de la mairie avec
plusieurs agents ils ont enrichi les
essaims le 17 juin dernier à nos ruchers
pas compliqué les essaims ont été mis
dans une petite boîte en polystyrène que
l'on appelle ruchette et nous allons
sortir toutes les abeilles de des
ruchettes pour les mettre dans leur
vraie ruche dans leur belleruche bien
grande
confortable et elles y resteront si tout
va bien
pendant de longues années pour le maire
lui-même apiculteur amateur c'est une
façon de sensibiliser aussi bien les
enfants que les agents de la commune à
protéger cette espèce indispensable nous
avons une ruche par groupes scolaires
donc chaque école à personnaliser sa
ruche et il va y avoir ensuite un
enseignant référent une classe référente
et cet enseignant et cette classe avec
l'aide bien évidemment des techniciens
d'un apiculteur vont s'occuper des
ruches
il va y avoir des séquences pédagogiques
autour de la vie de l'abeille de la vie
de la ruche la ville a aussi lancé une
campagne de financement participatif
objectif récupérer 5000 euros pour des
aménagements sur le rucher municipal les
bâtiments de france nous ont demandé une
clôture avec des règles architecturales
à respecter puisque nous sommes dans une
zone classée et là du coup c'est
beaucoup plus cher
voilà donc on va créer une clôture en
bois avec dessus de la documentation
pédagogique pour le moment la mairie a
récupéré un peu plus de 50% de la somme
soit 2600 euros et pour la première
récolte de miel
il faudra encore patienter un petit peu
jusqu'à juillet si tout va bien c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
l'information revient demain à 18h en
direct dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canale et d'ici là je souhaite
une très belle soirée
[Musique]